could these ufos be aliens now i'm going
into territory of you as a human being
wondering about all the alien
civilizations that are out there
the hum the humbling question
we are not alone
you think we're not alone there's it's
an improbability
that we are alone if by virtue of the
fact that sentient human life exists
intelligent human life exists
all the probabilities that would have to
be destroyed for that to be true
simply speak over the galaxies that
exist that there's no possible way we're
alone
it's a mathematical equation it's a it's
a one or a zero right and for me it has
to exist
it's impossible otherwise rationally for
me to think that we are truly the only
intelligent life form in all of the
universe
but
to think that
an alien life form is anything like us
at all
is equally as
inconceivable
to think that they're carbon-based
bipedal humanoid
uh alien species that just happen to fly
around in metal machines
and visit alien planets in a way that
they become observed
is
uh it's just silly it's the world of
sci-fi well
every good scientist
because we always assume that they're
superior to us in intelligence yes when
any scientist carries out an experiment
the whole objective of the experiment is
to observe without
being disclosed or being discovered yeah
so why on earth would we think that the
superior species makes the mistake of
being discovered over and over again
so to push back on that idea if we were
to think about us humans trying to
communicate with ants
first we observed for a while there'll
be a bunch of phds written a bunch of
uh sort of collecting data taking notes
trying to understand about this
thing that you detected that seems to be
a living thing which is a very difficult
thing to define from an alien
perspective or from our perspective if
we find life on mars or something like
that okay so you observe for a while
but then if you want to actually
interact with it how would you interact
with the ants
if i were to interact with the ants i
would try to
infiltrate
i would try to put like
figure out
what is the language they used to
communicate with each other
uh i would
try to operate at their physical scale
like uh in terms of the physics of their
interaction in terms of the
information methods mediums of
information exchange with pheromones or
whatever however the heck ants so i
would try to mimic them in some way so
in that sense it makes sense
that um
the objects we would see
you mentioned by peter yes of course
it's ridiculous that aliens would
actually be
very similar to us but maybe they create
forms in order to be like
here uh the the the humans will
understand it and this needs to be
sufficiently different from humans to
know that there's something weird i
don't know i i i think it's actually an
incredibly difficult problem of figuring
out how to communicate with a thing way
dumber than you
people assume like
if you're smart it's easy to talk to the
dumb thing but i think it's actually
extremely difficult when the
gap in intelligence is just orders of
magnitude and so of course you can
observe
but once you notice the thing is
sufficiently interesting
how do you communicate with that thing
so this is where
one of the things i always try to
highlight is how conspiracies are born
because
many people don't understand how easy it
is to fall into the conspiratorial
cycle
so the first step to a conspiracy being
born is to have an a piece of evidence
that is true
and then immediately following the true
evidence is a gap in information
and then to fill in the gap of
information
people
create an idea
and then
the next logical outcome is based on the
idea that they just created which is an
idea that's based on something that was
imagining in the first place
so the idea the factual thing is now two
steps away and then three steps away
four steps away as the things go on and
then all of a sudden you have this
kernel of truth that turned into this
wild conspiracy
so in our example
you talked about humans trying to
communicate with ants ants are not
intelligent
there's no ants are not intelligent
species they're drone species that's
somehow commanded through whatever
technology whatever whatever
like a typical human but yes whatever
biological thing is in the queen right
but they're they're not it's not a fair
equivalent but let's look at gorillas or
let's look at something in the monkey
family right where
largely we agree that there there is
some sort of intelligence there or
dolphins some sort of intelligence right
it is a human thing a human thing to
want to observe
and then communicate
and integrate
that's a human thing not an intelligent
life thing
so for us to even think that a foreign
and intelligent alien species would want
to engage and communicate at all is an
extremely human
assumption
and then from that assumption then we
started going into all the other things
you said if they wanted to communicate
wouldn't they want to mimic if they
wanted to mimic wouldn't they create
devices like ours so now we're three
steps removed from the the true fact of
there's something unexplainable in the
skies
yeah so the the the fact is there's
something unexplainable in the skies and
then we're cons we're filling in the
gaps with all of our basic human biases
and assumptions exactly but the thing is
now we're getting right back to project
northwood
we need some plan i don't care how crazy
the idea is guys give me some plan so
that's where we come up with well maybe
it's an alien species trying to
communicate or maybe it's an alien
a hostile threat that's trying to take
over the uh the world or who knows what
maybe it's but you have to
uh
you have to somehow construct hypotheses
and theories uh for anomalies
and then
from that
amidst giant pile of the ridiculous
emerges perhaps a deeper truth
absolutely over over a period of decades
and
and at first that truth is ridiculed and
then it's accepted you know that whole
the process um the earth revolving
around the sun yeah the earth revolving
around the sun and but you know to me
it's interesting because it asks
us looking out there with seti just
looking for alien life
is
forcing us to really ask questions about
ourselves about what is life how special
first of all what is intelligence how
special is intelligence in the cosmos
and i think it's it's um inspiring and
challenging to us as human beings
both on a
scientific and engineering level but
also on a philosophical level i mean all
those questions are laid before us when
you start to think about alien life
you